april is sexual assault awareness month
and the goal of this month is to shed
light on the stories of survivors the
group signs of hope which is a rape
crisis center is a major resource for
victims in the community during the
pandemic the group says they saw a
dramatic increase for counseling
services in 2021 they met with 450
people at hospitals for sexual assault
exams and handled more than 14 000
hotline calls and website visits they
continue to partner with las vegas metro
police to train hospitality workers on
how to spot and prevent predatory
behavior
it really is an opportunity to take a
lot of the
stigma and shame that survivors often
feel and just
begin talking more about this issue that
affects so so many people that we often
don't discuss and kind of keep in the
dark we also want all survivors out
there to know that we are here to
support them
signs of hope will kick off the month
with a community resource fair today
april 5th it's from 4 pm to 7 p.m in the
courtyard of the organization's office